[Music]
question in the back question Mike
Schneider from Indy wire what up
couldn't help but notice there's a lot
of hair on these faces up there is this
a solidarity thing or is it just a weird
coincidence that you all are hairy at
the same time it's just depression
yeah when actors don't work they very
quickly get depressed yes and we grow
beard three times as fast it's great and
usually when we're not doing veep we
play kind of musty characters can you
guys talk about I know there's been some
discussion about the show might return
in August what is the update on when you
go back into production last I heard it
was August we're coming back in August
yes we're sorry shorting shooting and
airing in 22 right yeah I was gonna
locked up rust from Holloway of life do
you know what how you want your
characters to end or you just leaving it
to the writers would you be okay
obviously you're okay with the writers
and stuff but yeah I'd like to jump off
a ledge really drunk one way just like
it's all been leading up to it I'd like
to work in the Game of Thrones yeah
a time machine yeah I mean if furlong
should become president
should be ambassador to NATO yeah
Clea what are you doing
Thea are you get up here get up here
winds roll your Sam Rockwell's related
questions hi Jeanne wolf I just want to
hear how you've been in touch with
Juliet has anyone called her tonight I
mean I know it just just happened and
and a report on how she's doing
the self service act in the thing is
actually pretty scary terrible and I
left my cell phone I left my cell phone
at the table so I got to remember to
pick that up
mine too it's just a mental note on the
phone she she's generally been in good
spirits when we've seen her she has a
good sense of humor which I think will
carry her along which I think it does
wonders if you're going through
something like this
so I mean she's incredibly strong and
she's sort of a uniquely able to combat
something like this I mean she's
incredible yeah yes and also on my phone
is at the table I just guys help me out
I do it whatever the globe hi Maureen
with II W this questions for Tony
dollars I know that you brought your
high school drama teacher with you
tonight and I just wondered if you could
talk a little bit about what that meant
to you and why you wanted to do that
yeah so Tina Williams was I was so
thankful to be able to bring her tonight
she intel has d florida she started this
children's theater when I was in well
she started way before when I was in
middle school I was having a hard time I
was into sports and then
parents got me into this theater and it
just changed my life so I'm incredibly
grateful to her and for her to be able
to experience this is like a gift to me
and to her so it's and it's kind of a
nephew and I hope they hear that I'm
hold on just one sec its sports teachers
yeah teaching that's what I called them
[Laughter]
I'm jyler with New York Magazine
Congrats can you guys talk a little bit
about how julia is such a leader you
know when the cameras aren't rolling and
how hurler her leadership has really
evolved throughout all these years
you've been doing the show all of us
were kind of a bunch of divas we started
beat but she doesn't have a bad day so
nobody can misbehave yeah and it's also
whoever's whoever's number one in the
call shoot she sets the tone and she has
just set a tone for everybody it's a
team it's a we're all a part of a team
nobody's walking on eggshells
everybody can throw in jokes she has no
arrogance no entitlement great
collaborator great collaborate and it
really creates his environment that's a
family and that's because all that other
stuff in teittleman and arrogance just
sucks creativity out of a room of a cook
and she's really good
trust her to that she would show up to
see that she's not in yeah she was there
she a key lime pie she makes her really
good key lime pie and chocolate chip
cookie and chocolate chip cookie we miss
her greatly here we wish you were here
congratulations I'm a huge fan so I have
to say that so I'm personally curious
how much of what you guys do is
improvisation we're versus scripted I
think any of us can answer this question
but so we the way that the kind of the
process for veep works is that we do
rehearsals with a script then we put
aside some of the improv that we do in
rehearsal kind of gets worked into the
script but by the time we were on set
it's all scripted but it has like some
of our personal stuff that we've we
worked through in the script but it's
all pretty much scripted like a hundo
and I will say that the more tell the
more that we've been on set the more
we'll ask for forgiveness rather than
permission to try something yes so that
is the thing I thank you thank you it's
that's right well I don't want to forget
it thanks 60 bucks cash up for the grabs
that's what Julie will do she'll come in
when she's not doing a scene and she'll
watch the monitors and say dirty da
dirty enough Jersey yeah shows it
judging so you're always on top of each
other and throwing stuff around and
making it and there's also they're also
like alts that come in you know so you
have the script as it is and then a new
joke will fly in you'll do the joke and
so it feels real fresh and new Gary Cole
gets the worst all's really incredibly
hard things to say that just come out of
nowhere like you know ninety percent of
atomic number for hydrogen or something
and they just throw this stuff at them
when we get a we get our takes
printed or whatever and I don't I don't
know how he does
conversely I get the best on invoker
[Laughter]
Jane McCabe has some nasty
[Laughter]
[Music]